the Joe Rogan experience uh am I crazy
to think Dominick Cruz can beat an Risa
who don't decision Dominick Cruz is a
legitimate bantamweight Henry cejudo
beat Marlin more eyes but Marlin arise
it seemed like kind of fell apart mm-hmm
got tired and fell approach he broke him
down Dominick Cruz we haven't seen he
doesn't get hurt really Kody garment
fight but yeah but he got real emotional
with cardi Cody gar Brown fight we don't
know where he's at physically he just
got off another surgery he's 36 37 now
which is old for a 135 pound fighter
burial but these guys are [ __ ] his
movement doing her man and Henry school
starts slow I seem getting down in
rounds to Dominic Dominic's impossible
to hit man and his movement is pretty
substantial that's a big factor if
there's a weird - it's awkward sis
wrestling's down switching the feet if
it's Dom and kind of that fashion I
don't know man it's a tough fight for
Henry cejudo well Dominick Cruz is a
tough fight for everybody he's not an
easy fight for anybody and also you know
I mean he's got to realize there's not a
whole lot more opportunities left if he
wins this one there are if he loses that
it's kind of like yeah if he loses it
it's over
just being an analyst for a little bit
well he's great at that the best he's
yeah one of the best yeah he's for sure
one of my favorites my favorites you
Anakin DC though well we me and DC have
a fun time man we get silly
he sees one of the guys yeah he's like
this yeah yeah
DC text me another day he's like one of
the guys yeah he gets silly he's getting
mad waiting around for Steve Bay you
know but I think I think the disservice
is DCI I love Steve a and he has the eye
issue and this time I came in a cage
well guys are freaking out it's like
dude if you're not gonna fight then we
gotta figure something out cuz the
heavyweight division UFC gave him some
sort of an ultimatum I don't imagine
that's what he said oh did he yeah yeah
there was an article about it today
whether there's there's some sort of uh
some sort of a discussion well what I
don't want is stupid to come back too
soon when he's not ready and lose that
fight
you know ruin a little bit of his legacy
yeah dude wait it out get that I better
let these guys do the thing that he come
back mm-hmm yeah I don't know if steepy
is ever gonna be able to fight again and
maybe he shouldn't you know that I it's
not worth it
he's he great yeah what if he does he's
still great he got poked quite a bit not
that first fight I rewatched that first
fight you got poked bad in the eyes
first fight with DC I don't know if
that's where the eye injury came from
but it could have been god I know DC I
don't see DC jumping on a bed to fight
Francis [ __ ] that
I think if Stevie backs off and says I'm
done you know my eyes are too precious
I think DC retires agree unless they
come up with some sort of wild 205-pound
fight for him that allows him to make
that cut again
[Applause]